[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour casser la pièce montée
on est à la Barbie
Sacha est venu me voir il m'a dit Cyril
j'ai un rêve
j'aimerais que Moshi
vient de chanter à ma bar mitzvah
j'aimerais qu'il vienne chanter
laisse-moi t'aimer de Mike Brant
[Rires]
je te souhaite une bonne année bonne
année
[Rires]
commencer par vous puisque il y a une
chose qu'on pourra jamais vous reprocher
c'est que vous dites toujours ce que
vous pensez que ce soit en rentable ou à
l'antenne on l'a vu vous êtes élu
l'honnête de la semaine l'honnête
l'honnête non mais c'est vrai
c'est mon problème
j'ai tenu le choc ouais vraiment bah oui
parce que ouais parce que tu sais ce que
c'est si tu vas qu'est-ce que tu vas
faire alors qu'aurais fait Cyril grande
question il nous a pondu un dixième de
seconde une réponse de très grand poète
tu sais ce que c'est si on prie
d'antenne toi tu vas qu'est-ce que tu
vas faire je vais je vais Ken
[Applaudissements]
désolé pour les nouveaux
je suis désolé c'était parce que voilà
c'était pour le bon mot
au repas ce soir
[Rires]
vous faites une excellente rentrée c'est
vrai que vous êtes un des meilleurs
animateurs du peuple hyper fort de
saison en saison c'est un peu moins le
cas pour certains chroniqueurs en
particulier les nouveaux qui auraient
mieux fait de se taire ah ouais ce sont
les relous de la semaine voilà c'est dur
[Musique]
je sais pas j'ai un peu Mario mais ça va
c'est Mario au premier regard ok bon bah
ça va alors
vous savez que Emmanuel Macron il a
ordonné formellement qu'on lui fasse un
crayon
[Rires]
et qu'elle a une façon de tenir sa tête
très droite est-ce que les hommes le
font parce que moi j'ai toujours rêvé
d'être à mon cou donc j'ai eu peur
tu peux pas survivre ici c'était pas
comme du rock
c'est la fin du mois qu'est-ce que tu
veux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
de la semaine je crois que c'est sur ça
est-ce que vous pouvez parler à tous les
chroniqueurs en face to faced comme ça
très proche bien sûr
alors je vous dis tout le monde
irréprochable je parle le niveau hygiène
bucco dentaire irréprochable alors là il
est en train de mentir
ne vous le dira jamais il enverra
toujours une tierce personne pour vous
le faire dire autre que c'était son fils
cette semaine on les a appelé c'est pas
vrai on les a appelé les stars banana de
la semaine
par contre on va en donner un
[Musique]
père ça donne ça
alors ça va
très bien
[Applaudissements]
je retrouve dans un instant
[Rires]
comment est l'ambiance entre les
chroniqueurs
[Rires]
par contre
comment est l'ambiance entre les
chroniqueurs c'est peut-être la question
que vous posez à la maison et bien
est-ce que certains se sont passionnés
pour les vacances des autres pour la
rentrée des autres et bien pas de ouf
l'ambiance c'est pas au bout fixe
exemple avec Gilles et Géraldine
[Musique]
la nuit sur l'autoroute pour le déluge
la voiture
pour moi c'est toujours comme ça
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez voler vous vous étiez un
petit peu dès qu'on revient je voudrais
des je vous donnerai le déteste et
debout avec de l'énergie
s'en bat les couilles
tu t'en fous total non me disant que
c'était tellement dramatique du coup
j'essaie d'augmenter le moral quoi
c'est fantastique
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'American staff alors partez en
fou rire mais en gros pour ceux qui
n'ont toujours pas vu cette séquence et
vous leur joignez et bien Cyril part en
fou rire il y a Nicolas pernicov qui
nous raconte une histoire là
vous partez en fou rire
voilà et vous faites quelque chose qui
vous ressemble pas du tout Cyril vous
êtes de mauvaise foi vous remettez la
faute sur quelqu'un d'autre
ton émotion te trahi tu vois bien que
c'est horrible
après aujourd'hui les Américains stuff
on est en train de les mélanger les uns
avec les autres
il a eu peur il a sauté sur le truc mais
tu ne peux pas faire aller à la mairie
pour le fait que c'est un chien qui ne
risque rien mais Nicolas ça vous fait
mal
ça te fait marier ça te fait mal
perdu
cette image mais le problème c'est que
cette séquence devient répétitive
puisque à chaque fois que Cyril en
fourrure maintenant il se tourne vers
Guillaume qui n'est pas là ce soir et
bien nous c'est le nouveau trampoline
c'est le mauvais choix de la semaine
j'adore
[Musique]
non moi je pense qu'il faut raisons
garder les mots du sens
parce que entre les causes que vous
défendez et les méthodes que vous
employez je trouve au final Google et
tout les causes que vous défendez elles
peuvent avoir une dimension de noblesse
on peut pas serrer avec les méthodes que
vous employez au contraire donc je crois
que vous faites attention vous êtes un
40000 à peu près de militants dans les
mouvements
si vous n'êtes pas 10 millions il faut
vous interroger c'est parce que l'action
que vous proposez est une action qui
n'est pas considérée comme suffisamment
démocratique la liberté d'expression
c'est pas la liberté de mener plusieurs
choses Guillaume
[Applaudissements]
on a tellement limité c'est comme Bruno
Pommard
le problème c'est une le pire c'est
Michel marine
la jeune Marie sort de chez elle elle va
acheter trois baguettes viennoises
et là sur son chemin elle croise un
certain Jean Walter
c'est genre
Walter écouter Gilles Verdun
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr
on sait qu'ils sont partis faire des
courses
notamment des beats framboises
[Rires]
une veste il était Nanterre dans le 4
lorsque Cyril rentre dans la pièce
[Rires]
on l'adore c'est pas des chats qu'il a
dans la barre c'est des Panthères mon
frère
[Rires]
c'est le meilleur Michel Marie je parle
de toi parce qu'avec ta petite voix il
est 19h49 merci
fais ton boulot avant de partir Cyril je
voulais qu'on voit ma séquence tu seras
tout seul je serai pas là bas j'ai déjà
mon diplôme enfin je voulais finir par
ma séquence et comment au niveau réparti
sur une échelle
vous savez sur ce plateau sur ce plateau
on reçoit beaucoup de personnes
d'inviter au look un seconde
vous le savez donc on reçoit beaucoup de
d'inviter au look insolites et ce qu'on
adore faire c'est fixer les têtes
regardez les réactions des gens juste
sachez un petit info pour le prochain
magnéto vous pouvez parler à la Régie
dans les micros c'est important de le
savoir vous pouvez si vous pouvez parler
à la Régie avec votre micro les gens le
savent pas ça oui et ben regardez le
prochain magnéto cyril a cru que c'était
une blague qu'est-ce que tu dis
j'explique aux gens les secrets de Let's
Go qui se garent
Bouchez vous qui connaissez mieux les
missions que moi qui ce gars non mais
c'est vous êtes qui d'accord donc je
vais parler à la résine dans ce match
des taux vous avez même cru que c'était
une blague mais regardez bien les têtes
ce sont les deux têtes de la semaine
tout simplement j'adore
[Musique]
alors si vous aussi vous avez cru une
blague de la prod regarde des biens
Moundir lui on est encore choqué à
l'heure où on se parle ça te tais est
exceptionnel
heureusement qu'il y a pas Guillaume
hein
dans une boîte de nuit bordelaise en
train de
s'amuser
avec toi
[Musique]
doutes de la mer
il était très sympathique en tout cas
très sympa très sympathique franchement
très sympa et on a on a kiffé avec le
tube YouTube
merci beaucoup ça me fait plaisir je
vous aime je vous aime tous
[Applaudissements]